it is so special compared to previous
ones is because it's a very rare
occasion where we have a solar eclipse
complete solar eclipse total solar
eclipse that passes over a major
observatory so we actually here have the
facilities to really analyze and study
the eclipses with with big telescopes
and sophisticated instruments we have
new experiments experiments that will
basically take spectra of solar corona
and they will basically try to figure
out why they have such high temperatures
we have a very interesting experiment to
actually look at mercury because mercury
is so close to the Sun normally we
cannot observe it
[Music]
it's the first time that I'm gonna see a
full solar eclipse so that's why we
decided to come here and also it's the
first time that I'm gonna visit the
stations today I spec to see something
amazing to see the moon straight keeping
a total eclipse
he repeat parable yet they don't sit
down for me a nunataq Teodoro Tico but I
killed it on to kuvira lacunae brothers
locally i puede Inglis la guerra de
tomar una fotografia and we're on the
wanna race over again student this
[Music]
[Music]
look me
Zadro regime was a minute ago in
original now a mill they use a
tarantella dollar tourism in Ferguson
alley well as infantile communal process
early they deport wiedersehen soco's al
dente level on la fortuna para que ellos
quieren a career say even a step back
tacular get tunnel tongue and Cialis you
[Music]